In this example I'm going to
join some core customer data
with a data set that includes
their first purchase date so
that I have that field appended
to the core customer data.
I bring in the Join tool and
attach the core customer data to
the left side marked with the L.
And the first purchase
data to the right side.
Whenever you bring in this tool,
the first thing you need
to do is configure how
the join is going to happen.
In this case, we have a customer
ID field in both data sets.
One is called Customer ID and
the other is just called ID.
So we can use this field for
both data sets.
As you can see here, the ID field
can have different names but
as long as you are manually defining
which fields to join together,
then they will join if the same ID
number exits in each of the data sets.
Let's run the workflow
to see the results.
If we look closely at the join tool,
we can see three outputs.
The J represents the data that was
joined together between the two sides.
We can see the core
customer data on the left.
And the first purchase
data on the right.
Notice how the ID field we use
to join with is duplicated.
Customer ID, and ID.
We can go back to the Join tool and
deselect it from the right side, so
it only comes through once.
So deselect the ID field.
And then we'll run the workflow again.
Notice how the ID field is no
longer shown in the final result.
If we take a look at the data
coming out of the L side,
this is the data from the left input
that did not join to the right input.
Because we're rejoining on that
customer ID field in the ID field,
this one record with
an ID of 456 does not
exist in the data coming
in from the right side.
We have six unique IDs
coming in from the left and
five unique IDs coming
in from the right.
So the result is five records joined.
With one record unjoined on the left.
If we look at the right side output,
we see no records there,
all of the input records from
the right side joined to the left.
It's important to be able to see
what does not join in your data
because this can help identify missing
records, dirty data or other issues